hi I'm Ernest Cline the author of ready
player one and also one of the
screenwriters of the upcoming film
adaptation ever I've mentioned a video
game it was always something from my
life for some you know a game that I
love for some reason that I wanted to
pay tribute to and have in the
background business and a graph is one
of my first 3d video games that I ever
played for the trs-80 color computer -
you play a warrior who has to descend
into a multi-level dungeon and defeat a
bunch of creatures and collect items and
the defeat an evil wizard and I just
really spoke to me as one of my favorite
games and I would play it late into the
night one of the first challenges that
Wade has to complete is go into a
recreation of James Holidays bedroom and
complete darkness of daga raft to unlock
the first gate
Zhora the great underground Empire one
of the first and best known text
adventure games and one of the first you
know virtual worlds that I ever explored
as a gamer even though it was kind of
based on texts you kind of had to map
out the playing area and collect a group
of treasures so that's another one of
the games that I wove into the book the
planet of frou Boz that's depicted in
the Zork games is an actual whole planet
in the Oasis where the text-based game
is recreated in virtual reality
pac-man one of the greatest blockbuster
video games of all time and one of the
few classic arcade games that actually
has an ending due to a bug in the code
it runs out of memory and you crash on
the 256 screen so it is possible to play
a perfect game of pac-man and get the
maximum amount of points that's another
one of the challenges Wade has to
complete his play a perfect game of
pac-man in which he is rewarded with an
extra life he gets the extra life
differently in the movie I did use a
MAME multi arcade machine emulator to
jump to the 256 screen using cheat codes
so I could play that screen and describe
way playing it from firsthand experience
as opposed to just watching videos takes
hours and years of skill this pac-man
even improved upon pac-man and had
better levels in the Atari 2600 port of
miss pac-man was far superior to the van
Dusen's nerve solver to dress
Black Tiger is also another kind of
classic arcade game like Zork it was a
game that you know almost caused a
couple of my friends to drop out of
college it was really just addictive you
have to send into a multi-level dungeon
and defeat multiple dragons and it's
recreated in the Oasis as a virtual
reality 3d experience so he gets sucked
into a black tiger cabinet in a bowling
alley arcade and then has to navigate a
three-dimensional or triolic recreation
of a black tiger using the same game
mechanics tempest where my favorite the
vector graphic videogames the designer
had a dream about monsters coming up
crawling out of a hole coming at him and
that helped inspire tempest it's one of
my favorite games then it's a game
that's also featured one of my favorite
music videos by the band rush
subdivisions the kid that's in the video
is playing Tempest so for all those
reasons I wove it into the story and
that's one of the games that need to be
defeated in the final challenge and the
character of Artemis helps Wade do so by
exploiting a bug did that from the
first version of tempest where your
score ended on a certain combination of
numbers you could get like thirty three
games on point quarter adventure back in
the eighties most of the games took
place on one screen but adventure it was
a whole kind of virtual world and you
could navigate with labyrinths in
different rooms and creatures and items
that you could pick up you would pick up
a sword that would look like an arrow it
was all very crude but it was such a
powerful experience when I was a kid and
was also the very first game to have an
Easter Egg hidden in it finding that
Easter Egg when I was a kid helped
inspire the whole story of ready player
one the idea of a brilliant game
designer hiding an easter egg in his
virtual world to find it worthy
successor for his fortune and it's
company all came from finding that
Easter Egg an adventurer the first
person to find the egg will inherit half
a trillion dollars and total control of
the Oasis that's why I'm so happy that
it made it all the way from my life into
the book and then into the movie sword
quests another video game that helped
inspire the contest in ready player one
Atari ran this amazing video game
contest through this series of four sort
quest games kids all over the country
would compete to be the first to beat a
sword quest game the first person who
win the grand prize would win these
amazing treasures and nothing got me
more excited as a kid
like a gold chalice and a gold crown
stuff that was worth like $30,000 in
80's money and I'm beating this game and
it was you know that was one of the
things that helped inspire the idea of
this video game contest inside the Oasis
see you at the finish line
Dallas is another one of my favorite
classic arcade games Williams
Electronics where you could battle one
of your friends and I remember lots of
like heated joust battles with my
friends growing up and so I wove that
into the story as well inside the first
gate at the end of a tomb of horrors
recreation the main character parsable
has to play a game of joust against a
Serra rack which is a Dungeons & Dragons
villain and defeat him and that's part
of the first challenge in the book a
callow bet is one of the first attempts
by a computer programmer to translate
the experience of playing Dungeons &
Dragons into a computer game I was
created by Richard Garriott who also
helped serve as the inspiration for
James Halliday Richard Garriott's a
famous video game designer from Austin
Texas where I lived who had an alter ego
of his Dungeons & Dragons and game
avatar called Lord British and he would
dress up as Lord British in public at
press events and things and he
eventually ended up using his video game
money to travel into space and go in
International Space Station so he was
really an inspiration to me as like a
geek with unlimited funds and what could
be accomplished so he and Howard Hughes
helped inspire James Halle in my book
and his game akalabeth and the games
that followed it's a Ultima one two
three four and then Ultima Online the
first MMO those all helped inspire the
oasis in my novel Dig Dug is another
weird 80s arcade game based on a job of
excavating and digging in the recreation
that parsable has to navigate of war
games panic goes into the movie of war
games and is in that 20 grand pallets
arcade and so I actually rewatched that
scene when I was writing about it and
when Matthew Broderick's playing Galaga
there's a Dig Dug game where his
notebook is resting on it so I added
that little detail so that's how Dig Dug
made it into ready player one
[Music]
Galaga is the game that Matthew
Broderick plays in wargames so that was
why it was mentioned and I remember they
sent him a copy of Galaga to his home so
he could practice for the movie pretty
cool you're kind of the first space
invaders ripoff where you had a shield I
like the name door more than the actual
game Worf somehow made it all the way
into the movie you can see a pleco
vision port of Worf at the end of the
film have requests one of the first
massively multiplayer online games after
ultima online and have requested you
know gave rise to a world of warcraft so
that was one of the you know first MMO
games where I saw people that I worked
with IT jobs people would bring their
laptops in and be like old farming and
grinding to get experience points while
they were working throughout the day and
I remember people like developing strong
relationships through this game of
EverQuest and meeting people online and
falling in love inside EverQuest I came
here to escape but I found love created
a new kind of human relationship like
there are people alive now because their
parents met inside of World of Warcraft
can you feel this so that was one of the
games that helped inspire the Oasis and
why I mentioned it and World of Warcraft
in the book tennis for to one of the
very very first video games ever made on
an oscilloscope which was really just a
rudimentary version of pong or the ball
bouncing back and forth space war a
bunch of model railroading nerds at MIT
created this game where you could one
ship battling another weather or even
monitors and they had to control their
ships using these switches that were
built into the pdp-1 computer that they
programmed it on using paper tape their
arms got sore so they went back to the
model railroading shop where they built
model trains and they built little
wooden boxes with switches and controls
on them creating the very first video
game controllers that they went back and
plugged in and played space war and
that's where it all began people
blossom cave was actually one of the
very first text adventure games
I think the first text adventure game
ever created which was kind of the first
virtual reality simulation on a computer
even though it was a world built with
just text it was still a you know a
world that you could navigate and pick
up items and slay creatures I think it's
referenced as a precursor to inspiring
Zork
also inspiring the game adventure Warren
Robinett drew inspiration from colossal
cave when he created the Atari version
Kombat was the game that shipped with
the Atari 2600 we got it for Christmas
in 1978 we you know didn't have to drop
quarters in we could just play it all
day long my brother and I would play
endlessly just blowing each other up
with tanks and biplanes when Wade goes
into a recreation in virtual reality of
James holidays bedroom that he's created
inside the oasis he finds a shoe box
next to the Atari that has all the Atari
games that he had when he was a kid and
I think these were the the best of my
recollection the same Tiger games that
my brother and I had when we were kids
combat which came with the Atari and
then space invaders you hold down the
reset switch when you turn the power on
on space invaders you could get double
shots pretty awesome hit fall
kaboom star Raiders the Empire Strikes
Back which I loved Star Master yars
revenge and et the video game I always
wished we had more games and so when I
was an adult I ended up kind of
collecting every Atari 2600 game ever
made to fulfill my childhood dream of
owning them all-star Raiders was one of
the first kind of flight simulation
space simulator games where I used to
build like a little cockpit in front of
my family's giant television in the
early 80s and pretend I was flying a
spaceship and had a little control pad
you could enter navigation commands and
love star Raiders asteroids one of the
greatest supporter sucking classic
arcade games of all time and one of the
first games I got on my Atari 2600
I would just play it endlessly and
remember and get a 4-digit scored that
it gets in 9999 you would flip over and
I would just spend my Saturdays flipping
that sucker over is nice
like it so that's my tribute to
asteroids centipede that was a game that
was in the lobby of my hometown movie
theater in Ashland Ohio and one of the
first games I ever played with uh with a
trackball and we were getting blisters
from playing centipede it was such a
fast-paced frenetic game one of my
favorites that was another game that I
have at my home another vector graphic
game and the game that actually helped
inspire my second novel Armada as well
think about battlezone is the first game
that was ever purchased by the US Army
and converted into an actual training
simulator for the Bradley Fighting
Vehicle they changed battlezone into a
game called Bradley trainer when I heard
about that I was like wow you can play a
video game and it can trained you to
actually do real combat there's like a
precursor to The Last Starfighter of
celebrating that idea oh man I got
really good at a video game my video
game skills could help save the world
[Music]
Astro smash was like a mash-up of space
invaders and asteroids where you have
asteroids falling towards you and you're
shooting them from a ship that goes
across the bottom of a screen and that
was the game that shipped with the
Intellivision when you first got brand
new and television that came with Astro
smash and we never had it on television
only the rich kids in my neighborhood
had one and so I'd have to go over to
their house and play astro smash mislead
jealous Astra smash I believe is a game
that parsable in age play in a chess
basement when they're arguing about
sword quest and Lady Hawks soundtrack
what's going on Mario Kart
fender is a game that I could never
master in the arcade to have this an
amazing elaborate control panel with a
joystick and buttons that were in a
really inconvenient array and so I would
always be killed and then once we got
the atari 2600 version at home i
mastered that so that's another one of
my favorites raka raka to a madness in
the Minotaur bedlam and pyramid those
were all text adventure games that I had
on analog audio cassette with my trs-80
color computer 2 which is my first home
computer and also the one that I played
dunya's a dagger wrath on and those
games I would have to put in a cassette
recorder and filled with a volume knob
and led the games from analog tape back
to digital on my trs-80 and play them
and I loved all of them and I think
those are adventure games that Halliday
has with this TRC to get in the novel
Berger time flew like Donkey Kong and
pac-man mixed together be having an
avatar that has to navigate a maze
you're a chef who has to build the
burgers
Wade creates his own Atari 2600 game
called the stacks about climbing through
the stacked trailer park where he lives
in 2045 Columbus is the fastest-growing
city on earth you have to climb ladders
and go across girder platforms and
things like that kind of inspired by
games like Donkey Kong and Burger Time
there are lots of video games in the 80s
that were kind of based on menial jobs
like tapper where you had to be a
bartender and like games where you like
had to put play at quarter and then you
know do a job I'd rather fight aliens
Huebert so frustrating I don't know why
I mentioned Qbert I think just because
it's a funny name and a funny-looking
creature and I like the way he would
swear when he would get killed
Qbert had his own cartoon for a while in
the 80s he was so popular when they said
Fame would go to my head hey weren't
kidding so props to Qbert Robotron 2084
is one my favorite games designed by
eugene jarvis the creator of defender
we had one joystick to move your
character and another joystick to pick
your firing direction so you can move
backwards but fire forwards in the
groundbreaking and full system for a
game and one of the most fast-paced
frenetic games where you would feel kind
of assaulted after you finish playing
watching somebody play that he's really
good at it at high speed is really
and that's what Wade does in the opening
scene when he's in the stacks he's
playing it on an old laptop that he's
salvaged and he's playing Robotron
because it kind of helps him you know
escape from his life and it's just him
versus the machine and I'm a big
Robotron fan Zach's on another game that
I used to have a coin-op version I would
cycle them out every few years because
after you have one game you know it's
why people usually get multi kids but
Zach's on one of the first 3d isometric
games where your ship could go up and
down at different altitudes and you had
to navigate through kind of these Flying
Fortresses exact times just one of my
favorite games as a kid with a great
name so that's why I mentioned it and
ready player one I'm pilot just an
awesome game from the 80s that I used to
love there was a sequel time pilot 84
that I also loved where you're flying a
ship and you slowly go back in time and
travel to different time periods and
you're fighting by planes and UFOs and
it's just a contra is one of those
two-player games like Ikari warriors
where you could like team up with your
buddy and then just battle through
multiple levels also the birth of the
famous contra code for a Nintendo game
so yeah that was another favorite
heavy-barrel was from the first games
that I could
one quarter because I would play it so
much on any world of power-ups and a
piece of work it's a game where you
navigate through a maze and go battle a
big and you collect these different
pieces of the heavy barrel giant gonna
just go away anything so heavy barrel
was one of my time wasting games in my
home town arcade vigilante we've
featured in the movie slacker shot in my
hometown by Richard Linklater as well I
like vigilante but also another one in
my hometown bowling arcade where you
just are a vigilante and you got to go
beat up street punks and took away their
knife and rescue your girlfriend I think
vigilante kid stuff crime fighter's was
a four-player beat him up game that so
was in the bowling alley in my hometown
and me and my thunders and Dragons
buddies would go down there and play for
player crime fighters and just love it
to death you could also beat up on each
other as opposed to beating up on the
bad guys so we spend a lot of time just
ruining each other's games and making
your friends tick in more quarters and
so crime fighter's is just in one of
those games that in the Oasis where they
pass by it is in the background
well max another game in my hometown
Aladdin's castle over in Mansfield Ohio
I think it was three players and another
kind of be in the medieval beat him up
game that we love so that's how old max
made it in there Smash TV made by the
very same people who invented Robotron
new gene Jarvis and his team and they
used the same control scheme of having a
new one in joystick to move and one
joystick to fire but it was two-player
so you could team up with your buddy
Smash TV was kind of like the running
man like a futuristic game show
contestants would get killed and kill
people and it's pretty dystopian and
brutal and I used to have it so I used
to have a point out my smash TV in my
home so that's why I threw it in the
book he fighted to you people started to
compete against each other beating each
other up and pettite of Lee I just had
friends that were just obsessive about
it I was never that good except with
chun-li which is why I'm so happy that
she's made it into our movie wait oh my
god
quake will the ancestor of doom when
doom and doom two landed it kind of took
over my friends and I took over our
lives it was the first kind of a two
dimensional virtual reality first-person
shooter game where you could jump in and
battle each other and think about doom
is you couldn't gonna go up and look up
and down and then when quake came out
that was even better and
three-dimensional you had mouse look and
you could look up and down Wake was like
virtual reality definite inspirations on
ready player one and we have a planet
doom which could very easily also be
planet quake but those are some of the
classic video games mentioned in ready
player one I doubt it but with we gave
it the old college try and if you think
of any others that we miss go ahead and
put them in the comments below are you
willing to fight help us save the Oasis